we start here at 5 32 with some breaking
news a homicide investigation has
prompted police to actually close part
of the 215 it's at the airport connector
we have hector mejia live near the scene
with the latest on the investigation
hector what have you heard from police
hey there well just in the last 15
minutes metro no rather nhp confirmed
they anticipate this closure to stay in
place for several more hours meanwhile
metro police confirm one fatality on the
scene along the highway one person
rushed to the hospital and at this hour
no word about any arrests let's show you
video from just the last hour here metro
homicide detectives here carrying out
this investigation so all eastbound
lanes of the 215 are closed starting at
the airport connector tunnel traffic is
being diverted off the highway through
the warm springs exit during our drive
here in the last hour we saw those
detectives walking along the highway as
they carried out this investigation we
have live team coverage for you this
morning to help you navigate this
closure let's send it over to nate
tannenbaum who has the latest on that
good morning nate morning hector thank
you so much for that live report in the
meantime your monday commute is not bad
with that one exception and it is a big
one a lot of folks take the 15 to get
onto the 215 to get down to henderson
and right now you have to find another
way around as hector mentioned one death
confirmed a live picture from the
regional transportation commission so
these headlights those are the folks who
are westbound coming from henderson
heading over to the i-15 so what do you
do if you're stuck in that closure well
drivers are being you're being diverted
off to the airport connector tunnel so
go north as if you're going to the
airport however just before the tunnel
there is an exit to sunset so take
sunset over to eastern kind of a long
detour but it will get you back onto the
freeway when you take eastern all the
way down to windmill take a quick jog to
the west that will get you back onto the
215. we're continuing to cover this toy
we'll have the latest for you throughout
the morning and again the rest of
freeway system off to a decent start